[Musique]
bienvenue pour ce premier numéro de
votre magazine olympique sur tv 60,18
vous le savez en 2024 paris accueillera
l legio et notamment à montigny le
bretonneux se dérouleront les épreuves
cyclistes ici au vélodrome nationale en
attendant c'est à tokyo du 23 juillet au
8 août pour les jeux olympiques puis du
24 août au 5 septembre pour les jeux
paralympiques que vous pourrez suivre
les épreuves mais qui sont justement
aller à d'athlètes yvelinois qui
participeront à ces olympiades japonaise
présentation dans un instant de ces
sportifs et de leurs ambitions pour cet
été et pendant que le japon accueille
les jeux la france y préparer avec l
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines nous reviendrons sur la
dernière journée olympique au golf
national ou 500 jeunes se sont rendus à
cette occasion nous avons également
échangé avec les principaux responsables
des fédérations sportives et des
champions de haut niveau elle montigny
le bretonneux elancourt ou encore
versailles les sites olympiques seront
bientôt en chantier pour recevoir au
mieux les épreuves que les spectateurs
nous vous donnerons tous les détails
[Musique]
et pour débuter et focus donc sur ces
jeux olympiques et paralympiques qui se
déroule à tokyo qui sont les athlètes
yvelinois engagé présentation avec
michael et demi d'euros cet été les
yvelines seront bien représentés pendant
ces jeux olympiques de tokyo le
contingent évinois devrait être composée
d'une dizaine de sportifs parmi eux
trois triathlètes du club de poissy
seront de la partie dorian coninx
cassante beaugrand et léonie périodes
cette dernière connaîtra ses premiers jo
c'est un honneur de représenter kouassi
parce qu'en effet pas je les côtoie
depuis
depuis je pense 2010 par là donc c'est
vraiment bas c'était le but et on a
réussi en golf antoine ros nord du golfe
de la boulie à versailles représentera
la france sur cette compétition après
une année 2009 un teint de haut niveau
une victoire au qatar masters
à 28 ans le sportif espère remporter une
médaille en aviron la rameuse claire
bové de l'association sportive mantaise
fait partie des favoris dans son sport
pour un podium cet été un podium ce
serait franchement c'est un beau rêve
on a les armes pour se battre dans la
catégorie et pour faire des belles
choses donc c'est un beau rêve mais un
petit peu réaliste quand même aussi qui
se meut sur piste ils seront plusieurs à
partir au japon la fédération française
a décidé de miser sur la jeunesse avec 4
pépite mathilde de gros 21 ans sébastien
vie j'ai 24 ans rennes et la halle 22
ans et florian grings bovins en dix ans
y est aux vcs skyteam vous sert le réel
objectif
une carrière sportive de haut niveau qui
est la médaille aux jeux olympiques donc
très content mais il ya encore beaucoup
de travail et pourrait chercher la plus
belle des médailles en bmx cinq sportifs
qui s'entraînent sur le stadium à côté
du vélodrome nationale vont s'envoler
pour les jeux on retrouve dans la
sélection manon valentino axel etienne
silva andré le triple champion du monde
joris daudet ou encore romain mahieu je
pense que pour chaque sportif de haut
niveau participe aux jeux olympiques
c'est le plus gros objectif d'une
carrière donc super content ça va juste
la première étape
maintenant on va y aller
pour une médaille ce qui est voilà ce
qui est le rêve est et pourquoi on
travaille tous les jours
en judo à 34 ans guillaume chaîne
participera à ses premiers jeux
olympiques après avoir été remplaçant en
2016 à rio
judoka espère faire briller son club de
sartrouville au niveau international
dans la catégorie des moins de 73 kg
l'objectif comme chacun des athlètes qui
se présente aux jeux olympiques j'espère
pour eux c'est d'aller décrocher l'or
maintenant moi c'est mes premiers jeux
olympiques donc c'est déjà une petite
victoire en soit maintenant j'y vais pas
pour figurer non plus en boxe maiva
hamadouche a réussi à se qualifier pour
les jeux olympiques la sportive du
boxing club saint quentin en yvelines
sera dans la catégorie des moins de 60
kg une grande première pour cette
boxeuse passé professionnel en 2013
c'est dur surtout quand on est un boxeur
professionnel jamais vraiment laissé des
jeux olympique de côté parce que savoir
quand on est sportif
quand on est bon sur professionnels on
n'a pas le droit de se poser en douceur
hennebicq ça s'est ouvert pour les ans
nos pros arrive aulas s'est ouvert la
semaine pour les femmes également
l'apport tokyo un très chaud ces jo sur
les régions tout simplement
donc en fait pour moi c'est une chance
inestimable
enfin en bas le versailles et valentin
porte devrait faire partie de l'équipe
de france à tokyo champion du monde avec
les experts en 2015 et 2017
l'arrière droit espère remporter cette
fois ci un titre olympique avec la
sélection tricolore
c'est yvelinois vont-ils tous performer
à tokyo réponse à partir du 23 juillet
une fois terminées ces épreuves à tokyo
tous les regards vont se tourner vers
paris paris et sa région plusieurs city
minois vont être à l'honneur
présentation des sites
c'est officiel les yvelines vont
accueillir cette discipline sportive
pendant les jo de 2024
les sites ont été définitivement adoptée
le 17 décembre dernier par le comité
d'organisation versailles organisera le
cyclisme sur route à proximité du
château ainsi que des épreuves de
pentathlon moderne la ville royale
recevra également les épreuves
d'équitation un temps pressenti à la
mode devront nous on savait que toutes
les chansons étaient avec nous parce que
c'est un site totalement exceptionnel
d'accueil
et puis l'environnement à saint quentin
en yvelines au vélodrome nationale
accueillera bien le cyclisme sur piste
et recevra les preuves des scream du
pentathlon moderne à une centaine de
mètres des courses de bmx seront
organisées enfin le golf national
recevra les épreuves golfique six ans
seulement après la ryder cup 2018
ce qu'est le bien par rapport aux jeux
olympiques ce que ça va toucher
certainement une environ public un petit
peu plus large que la ryder cup parce
que la ryder cup
peut-être que ça touche est uniquement
un public d'avertis de golfeurs alors
que les jeux olympiques
peut-être touché des personnes qui
peut-être sont pas susceptibles de
penser au golf alors en tant qu'activité
olympique
enfin la colline d'elancourt et ses 230
mètres d'altitude accueillera les
épreuves de vtt en 2024
une nouvelle attendue depuis de longs
mois par le vc ou skyteam vous sert le
club local qui organise chaque année la
revancharde une compétition cycliste sur
le site
c'est nous honoré parce que ça fait 25
ans bec on reconnaît sur ce terrain là
on a fait la première revancharde
on est les seuls utilisateurs qui vont
nous vtt ici en compétition et pour nous
c'est une grande réussite c'est un
bonheur un bonheur partagé par tous les
adhérents du club les yvelines sont
aussi hautes de 2 sites paralympiques le
para équitation sera programmée dans le
parc du château de versailles et le
vélotour national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines accueillera
les épreuves de paracyclisme sur piste
la préparation des différents sites va
se poursuivre pendant plusieurs mois et
notamment l encours la colline point
culminant de l'île de france avec ses
231 m elle va accueillir les épreuves de
vtt à quoi va ressembler ce site encore
en friche plusieurs réunions
préparatoires se sont déjà tenues c'est
une nouvelle étape pour la colline
d'elancourt la solide et aux maîtres
d'ouvragé du projet a choisi cinq
entreprises pour aménager le futur site
qui accueillera les épreuves de vtt des
jeux olympiques de paris 2024
nous avons beaucoup avancé entre autres
avec l'architecte spécialisés pour la
création des pistes d'un point de vue
sportif c'est à dire que le tracé des
pistes est arrêté je dis bien des pistes
à dire de la piste de paris 2024
elle-même mais également des pistes
secondaires annexes qui seront ouverts
au grand public une fois que les jeux
olympiques seront passées et puis nous
travaillons aujourd'hui je dis bien que
nous travaillons toujours avec la soli
deo sur les projets d'aménagement 10
millions d'euros d'investissements sont
prévus pour le projet sans constructions
en dur sur le site et avec une portée
écologique pour que de futures familles
sportifs amateurs et promeneurs puissent
s'y balader nous pensons pour les
aménagements pour ce que l'on appelle
l'héritage c'est à dire rendre encore
plus vert et pérenne l'ensemble de tout
ce que vous voyez plantés sur ce site
avec un point culminant à 2 131 mètres
d'altitude
les élus locaux espèrent voir en ce
nouveau lieu un vrai emblème de réussite
de ces jo 2024 il sera ouvert et
accessible
sachant qu'aujourd'hui certes la colline
est ouverte mais elle est difficilement
accessible
il ya des chemins qui sont même je
dirais de dangereux par moment puisque
il s'est quand même assez pentue c'est
compliqué d'y monter et de l'esthétique
n'aura rien à voir avec ce que c'est
aujourd'hui ça demeurera bien entendu le
point le plus haut d'île de france je
vous rappelle que du sommet de la
colline on voit la tour eiffel et envoie
tout paris mais ça sera également
certainement le point le plus
écologiquement respecté qui aura un vrai
bénéfice à la venue des jeux olympiques
de paris 2024 pas de date précise pour
les premiers coups de pioche mais en
attendant le département travaille déjà
sur les dispos
six types de caméras pour une meilleure
retransmission possible et avant de
pouvoir découvrir ces nouveaux sites
olympiques il va surtout falloir fédérer
le public
et quoi de mieux pour fédérer le public
que d'impliquer les plus jeunes le 23
juin dernier l'agglomération de saint
quentin en yvelines proposer une journée
à d'animation avec des rencontres des
échanges et puis des activités tout cela
sur le site du golf national le
reportage de grégory canal et elle trône
à ce jour n'est pas parce que je garde
plein d'activités tant nouveau sport
qu'on n'a pas testé
on a fait dieu de tir au pistolet et on
a fait de la course
ça fait du bien au corps ici c'est
amusant c'est tout les guerres
c'est la génération 2024 ces jeunes vont
vivre dans trois ans les jeux olympiques
en france c'est pour faire monter
l'engouement saint quentin en yvelines a
convié cinq cents élèves de 18 collèges
de l'agglomération au golf national ce
mercredi 23 juin une trentaine
d'ateliers au programme pour découvrir
les disciplines olympiques et
paralympiques
c'est une manière très importante de
permettre aux enfants de s'accaparer les
jeux olympiques et les valeurs de
l'olympisme qui sont très importantes
les valeurs du sport
mais la peur de l'olympisme tout
particulièrement si j'étais retrouvera
pratiquement toute la place cette
journée était aussi l'occasion pour ces
jeunes de faire la connaissance de
sportive de haut niveau parmi les
athlètes présents l'ancien handballeur
olivier girault capitaine de l'équipe de
france championne du monde en 2001 et
médaillé d'or aux jo de pékin en 2008
moi petit c'est comme ça aussi que j'ai
évolué j'aurais voulu que des champions
qu'on réussit qui ont réussi reviennent
transmettre c'est un plaisir de
devenir transmettent et il ya plein de
gamins plein d'éducateurs plein de
bénévoles voilà tout l'écosystème du
sport ai réunis c'est une super
initiative donc obligatoire d'être
présent à la mi journée les jeunes ont
pu assister à des démonstrations du
tumbling avec la présence d'axel duriez
du club des clayes-sous-bois double
champion du monde des 13 14 ans bmx flat
football freestyle ou encore breakdance
la discipline sera olympique en 2024
c'est important de la faire connaître
d'ici là pour carlotta dudek
à 19 ans elle rêve de participer aux jo
de paris ça permet un petit peu d'avoir
un premier contact avec nous et du coup
nous ensuite on va pouvoir échanger avec
leurs deux noms rigolos apprendre les
mouvements
donc nous c'est tout ce qu'on aime
pouvoir leur montrer leur apprendre et
et avant leur bonne humeur et tout la
vente ayant entouré
saint-quentin-en-yvelines accueillera
cinq épreuves des jo en 2024 au golf et
vélodrome nationale et sur la colline
d'elancourt rendez vous donné dès
l'année prochaine pour une nouvelle
journée olympique et vous l'avez aperçu
dans ce reportage la championne carlotta
du dec était présente au côté des plus
jeunes la championne de break dance sera
pour la première fois aux jo à 2024 et
sa préparation a déjà débuté et
ambitieux et ouais c'est clairement de
participer aux jeux d'arènes 1 4 2 pour
décrocher une médaille et c'est un grand
événement c'est nouveau pour nous donc
aujourd'hui on va dire que le mot
d'ordre c'est de profiter
profitez de tout le processus avant d'y
être justement parce qu'il ya plein de
choses qui se développe justement des
moments comme ça c'est des choses qui
pour profiter justement qui sont à
l'occasion des jeux la préparation a
déjà commencé par les dominants 4 ses
lois mais c'est aussi tout près au final
ça arrive très vite donc on commence
déjà à se préparer avec l'équipe de
france a et a monté au plus haut niveau
autre champion impliqués dans cette
préparation des jo à paris en tant
qu'athlète expérimenté cette fois ci le
champion de handball olivier girault lui
aussi était présent au golf national le
23 juin dernier écouter son message le
sport il est il est social c'est
vraiment un endroit où on se retrouve
avec certaines règles apprendre à vivre
le sport ça prendra des associés de près
cet héritage dans les basses et suivi
qu'il va falloir communiqué pendant ces
trois ans qui nous reste juste jeux
olympiques un événement juste
extraordinaire parce que il est souvent
télévisuelle et très peu de gens ont
cette occasion de pouvoir être présent
et de vivre cet instant qui est magique
là on a la chance de l'avoir
après parents ça pendant 3 ans donne
envie à des gamins de faire du sport
mais pas seulement parce que
l'écosystème du sport ce n'est pas
seulement ce qu'on voit à la télé parce
que autour d'un match de sport il ya
tout il ya tous les métiers qui sont qui
sont dedans
profitons-en pour faire progresser nos
jeunes je vous propose à présent de
passer un peu plus de temps au golf
national où patrice carmouze a eu
l'occasion de rencontrer les principaux
responsables des fédérations de danse de
golf ou encore de rugby mais aussi
d'échanger avec jean philippe gatien le
champion de tennis de table et directeur
des sports de paris 2024 bienvenue dans
cette émission spéciale organise depuis
la journée olympique qui se situe sur le
sur le golf le golf national à saint
quentin en yvelines on va parler voix
par les jeux olympiques wade il parlait
évidemment tokyo qui commence le 20
juillet on va parler aussi de paris 2024
avec mes invités et de très très beaux
et grands invité pascal grizot bonjour
bonjour le président de la fédération
française de golf et vous être notre
route puisque on est chez vous vous êtes
les bienvenus
merci de nous accueillir la merci d'un
plaisir cette journée on va en voir
parler évidemment de cette journée
charles ferreira bonjour bonjour vous
êtes le président de la fédération
française de danse ont des danses
sportives dans une sorte de danse ont
dit de dresse tout simplement semer on
va parler de breaking danse avec vous
qui est qui va être au jour 2024 c'est
ça en 2024 tout à fait à côté de moi
jean philippe gatien bonjour vous êtes
le directeur des sports de paris 2024
alors est ce que c'est la patte de vos
preuves te rappelles vous a été le
meilleur joueur de tennis de table
français de tous les temps on dit ça un
meilleur je sais pas je n'ai fait un
petit peu dans un peu voilà il était
champion du monde j'ai été vice-champion
olympique à barcelone
et puis vous êtes toujours intéressé on
va en parler aussi beaucoup dans la
promotion du sport et au rôle social et
éducatif du sport à côté vous didier
retière bonjour bonjour vous êtes le
directeur technique national de la
fédération française de rugby et le
rugby sera sera aux jo de tokyo
et puis christophe man un bon jour je
vous êtes de directeur technique
national de la fédération française de
cyclisme
donc vous n'êtes pas très loin non plus
vous vous êtes con et pas chez vous mais
pas loin
tout à fait une somme sur le territoire
de saint quentin en yvelines donc sur le
vélodrome stade vélodrome de l or vous
le city dont on en reparlera mais enfin
c'est l'un des sports d'un des cinq
sports je crois qui est depuis tout
temps été aux jeux olympiques
oui bah c'est un sport on va dire un
sport olympique avec plusieurs
disciplines donc nous allons concourir
pour 19 titres sur les 22 qui sont
qu'ils sont possibles pour le cyclisme
donc voilà dans toutes les disciplines
de du cyclisme la piste la route le vtt
et le bmx freestyle et res et les
cyclistes sont déjà à tokyo ah non non
non les six qui sont en train de se
préparer dans divers endroits en france
encore en train de participer à des
compétitions pour parler d'un entonnoir
on va commencer peut-être par cette
journée cette journée olympique
pourquoi c'est important de l'organiser
pourquoi vous d'ailleurs vous avez
accepté de l'organisme sur le club soit
si on nous le demande donc nous on est
très gentil envers ravis d'accueillir on
a de l'espace
et puis c'est vrai que le golf national
est un site olympique mais c'est vrai
que les jeux olympiques c'est la
fraternité c'est le seul événement
sportif où tous les sports sont présents
et pour nous ça nous change un petit peu
là on est sur le practice où
généralement les joueurs s'entraînent et
la mieux heureusement là et là
aujourd'hui on a la chance d'accueillir
de nombreux jeunes réveiller pratiquer
et découvrir un grand nombre de sports
et c'est merveilleux et on est ravi
d'accueillir tous ces sports et tous ces
jeunes jean philippe gatien louis
norgari une journée comme celle là ça
permet justement il ya beaucoup de
collégiens beaucoup de lycéens qui sont
là deux jeunes de découvrir les sports
qui vont être présentés au juge ou c'est
un peu ça l'idée
ouais c'est un peu l'objectif sa tournée
l'impie qu'elle est elle existe elle a
été lancé par le comité international
olympique depuis
et puis plusieurs se maintient nous
depuis la phase de candidature de paris
aux 24 on avait initié un événement
majeur autour de cette journée olympique
malheureusement le contexte aujourd'hui
n'a pas permis ce qu'on avait fait par
exemple en gagner sur la place de la
concorde mais on s'appuie sur le
dynamisme des collectivités des
agglomérations et saint quentin en
yvelines est un exemple parfait 500
jeunes qui découvrent 32 disciplines où
trente deux initiations c'est juste
l'esprit olympique et cette nécessité de
faire découvrir au plus grand nombre des
jeunes la pratique et la pratique
sportive et encourager la pratique en
club parce que c'est aussi ça derrière
qu'il ya oui c'est en a on a
l'impression que vous fondèrent derrière
alors il ya évidemment les champions on
va en parler il ya tous ceux qui vont
concourir aux jeux olympiques mais
l'idée que la gloire la force loger dit
parfois de ses champions il faut que ça
rejaillit aussi sur la population quoi
complètement je pense que les jeux c'est
une c'est une vitrine le sport de haut
niveau c'est une vitrine c'est suscite
des vocations on et de nombreux
champions à avoir démarré une carrière
de sportif de haut niveau une carrière
de sportif tout court parce qu'on a vu
des images incroyables la télé donc
oreilles je pense que c'est ça
l'objectif est cette année cette journée
olympique elle a une saveur un peu
particulière parce que en sort d'un
contexte complexe et on a essayé de la
tournée en lien avec le cnosf et le cp
sf comité olympique et le comité
paralympique vers un encouragement pour
l'ensemble des équipes de france qui
vont être privés de supporters à tokyo
puisqu'il aura pas de supporter le
manger et on a décidé de lancer
aujourd'hui sur cette journée olympique
un numéro numéro whatsapp le 06 88 88
2024 alors 06 88 88 2024 exact qui va
permettre à l'ensemble des gens qui le
souhaitent d'enregistrer photos vidéos
messages ou simplement texte et qui
seront adressés à l'ensemble de la de
l'équipe de france olympique et
paralympique pour qu'ils se sentent
soutenus
donc on encourage la pratique sportive
et à chaque fois que vous pratiquez le
sport vous mettez un petit whatsapp un
petit message cette équipe de france si
vous le souhaitez ça lui fera bien du
bien oui parce que c'est vrai que là
c'est un peu particulier quand même pour
les pour les sportifs qui vont
participer aux yeux
par exemple les cyclistes avec
d'habitude yade et voilà il ya des
supporteurs et des gens qui viennent là
il ya quand même un peu de retour il y
aller il ya les équipes et les autres
renner il ya tout ça mais qui est
qu'est-ce qui peut venir les supporter
théoriquement personnes
théoriquement mersa là le cojo japonais
a annoncé donc la présence de
spectateurs mais uniquement les locaux
les locaux tant sur des jauges à 50% en
ce qui concerne les français ben nous on
sera à fall et sportives seront soutenus
par parler par les staffs en
l'occurrence pour le cyclisme une
quarantaine de personnes mais voilà
c'est tout il ya que les personnes
accréditées qui ont le droit de mettre
le pied sur le territoire japonais
c'est très très particulier interrogé
puisque vous faut vous avez des sportifs
qui ils vont participer à ces jeux pour
eux est ce que c'est plus compliqué pour
ce n'est pas pour se préparer ou est ce
que parce qu'il ya quelque chose qui va
me manquer à votre avis où est ce que
bon pour eux après tout une compétition
comme une autre et il ya enfin et de
communes autres pays comme une autre
parce que cdi où il faut être au
meilleur de soi même
quelles que soient les circonstances oui
alors vous l'avez dit vous-même les jo
de son pagne qu'on attention les yeux
grosse grosse pression sur son nous est
l'être pour performer là bas mais moi je
pense que ce qui au moins pour les
cyclistes ce qui est le plus difficile
pour nous c'est le manque de références
et le manque de compétition pendant la
dernière année et demie notamment les
pistards
voilà et non aux jo sans confrontation
officielle avec nos adversaires depuis
février 2020 donc ça c'est voilà on est
prêts on sait qu'on est en forme on
s'est bien préparé mais par contre c'est
la grande incertitude par rapport aux
niveaux au niveau international après on
a d'autres d'autres disciplines qui ont
pu concourir et notamment le vtt là on
sait qu'on est fort mais bon voilà c'est
ça va être la différence
au delà de l'ambiance qui va régner là
bas avec djo sans supporters français et
dans des conditions sanitaires en
revient encore une réunion de
préparation ce matin des conditions
sanitaires qui vont être assez assez
terrible c
et c'est public il y aura respecté enfin
il faudra les respecter compliqué oui
et du coup alors les jo de tokyo était
reporté un donnant à cause de la crise
sanitaire
on a alors j'ai pas dire que c'est djo
diminué mais c'est vrai qu'il lui dit si
on ce qui pousse un peu enfin on a
presque envie que ces vieux os déroule
depuis ce style nice pour qu'on passe à
paris votre cap ce n'est pas après ça ne
veut pas diminuer du touât les jo de
tokyo parce que non non et on a mis des
athlètes qui s'y prépare ça serait ça va
être des jeux sportivement peut-être un
petit peu différent mais je nul doute
que le sport va reprendre ses droits
et quand on les appelait seront aux jeux
ils vont être là pour pour gagner ce jeu
on aura des beaux jeux dans des
conditions particulières c'est une
évidence et on pense beaucoup nous et à
nos collègues japonais qui ont le rôle
d'organisateur ce qu'ils on sait que
quand même des moments assez sexy a été
compliqué pour mais on va on va nous
déplacer un petit peu en réduisant
fortement le nombre de personnes mais
pour aller quand même observer puisque
c'est important et on n'aura pas
beaucoup d'autres occasions de voir ça
et on aura surtout au nom de tous que
lors de la cérémonie de clôture donc le
8 août la passation
entre tokyo et paris puisque la mère de
tokyo donnez le drapeau olympique a
la maire de paris madame hidalgo et donc
on va véritablement basculé dans
l'olympia de paris
et on va devenir un petit peu le centre
du monde pendant pendant les sept
prochaines années donc on s'y prépare il
ya des éléments festif qui sont en train
de se préparer justement pour cette
prestation et ses douze minutes qu'on va
qu'on va devoir gérer à la fois
d'antenne dans le stade à tokyo mais
aussi sur sur paris et on vous concocte
quelques quelques surprises à c'est
assez sympa mais ça va être un moment
très fort très intense pour pour nous
dans lequel y aura un mariage un peu
sport culture pour pour lancer
l'olympiade c'est ce que dit tenez pas
votre collègue tony estanguet il dit
tous les tous les regards du monde va
être tourné vers paris le 8 août
ça va nous obliger un petit truc alors
on va peut-être parler un peu de ddj ou
de l'importance pour chacun des sports
que vous représentez pascal grizot
j'avais une phrase vos prédécesseurs qui
est georges barbaret qu'ils aient le
golf quand elle de golf a été admis aux
jo dan peek le golf sort enfin du ghetto
il était confiné depuis tant d'années
c'est un bouleversement majeur pour le
golf au niveau mondial et au niveau
français c'est vrai qu'il ya eu il
essayait dé sortie du ghetto levé je
sais pas si ghetto c'est tout à fait
vous répondriez mais j'adore georges
donc ils peuvent se permettre
d'abord ils ont rappelé que le golf a
déjà été président jeux olympiques au
début du siècle bernard très envahissant
vous dire pardon je vous interdis juste
une seconde mais on en parlera pour le
rugby aussi parce que c'est vrai qu'on
dit parfois voilà ces nouveaux jeux mais
il ya eu des jeux olympiques où il ya eu
des sports qui était de les représenter
et c'est le capitole exactement et donc
le golf est revenu aux jeux de rio sera
présent à tokyo est évidemment en 2024
ici au golf national et on en parlait
tout à l'heure en disant que pour
certaines fédérations c'est une très
grande importance de de faire partie de
la famille olympique
et c'est vrai que pour nous aussi on a
la chance d'être un sport qui est
relativement médiatisé mais par contre
c'est vrai que souvent la critique qu'on
fait aux golfeurs c'est de pratiquer
quelque chose qui n'est pas un sport est
justement le fait de pouvoir dire qu'on
fait partie de la famille olympique
légitime le fait que le spock le golf
est un sport
donc oui pour nous ça a été très
important de pouvoir
de nouveau refaire partie de la famille
olympique quelles sont les épreuves
qu'elle lieu dans les jeux où il ya des
individuels c'est par équipes ne sont
que des épreuves individuelles donc une
semaine pour les épreuves féminines une
semaine pour les épreuves masculines sur
le format habituel que jouent les
joueurs quatre jours voilà en stroke
play comme taupe raconte ton contre tous
ses coups et simplement ben voilà c'est
les jeux olympiques mais c'est le même
format clé compétitions habituelles que
jouent tous les joueurs et les joueuses
chaque semaine vous avez dit allez voir
les les
les parcours de tokyo sur lesquels alors
non non et en plus le parcours de tokyo
a changé au départ il y avait un
parcours qui avait été choisi et
finalement les jeux se dérouleront sur
un autre sur un autre gueule et j'ai pas
eu l'occasion d'aller d'aller à tokyo
pour voir le parcours j'avais pas non
plus été à rio c'était mon prédécesseur
jean louis charon qui avaient fait le
déplacement et malheureusement je ne
pourrai pas aller à tokyo pour les jeux
pour ceux dont on a parlé tout à l'heure
le respect des sanitaires
combien de deux joueurs français 4 donc
on a le deux joueurs et de joueuses
perez victor perez antoine ros mère
céline boutier et perrine delacour qui
évoluent tous les quatre sur le circuit
mondial un peu plus souvent aux états
unis ou en europe sont en forme en plus
qu'ils sont qui sont en forme et avec
j'espère une participation pour victor à
la prochaine ryder cup à la voile à
temps on espère on espère qu'il sera lui
dans la ryder cup
il n'y avait pas eu de france et quand
le
grossesse et des volumes impressionnants
il parlait de la ryder cup par le vent
et il ya eu un effet ryder cup sur le
nombre de licenciés vaut ce canal alors
il ya eu un effet sur le sur le nombre
de golfeurs en france et on se plaît à
la fédération a mesuré la période
2008-2010 8 pourquoi parce qu'en 2008 on
a commencé à candidater en 2008 on a
organisé l'événement
et pendant cette période là la
fédération française de golf a augmenté
son nombre de licenciés de 3% et demi ce
qui est faible au regard d'un
pourcentage 3% et demi sur dix ans est
très faible mais quand on le met en
perspective avec les autres fédérations
notamment des autres des fédérations
européennes mais également la fédération
américaine toutes ont perdu en nombre de
licenciés
quand on dit souvent l'évolution du
nombre de licenciés est liée à
l'émergence de champions
bah on s'aperçoit dans le golfe s'est
pas toujours le cas parce que un pays
comme l'irlande va venir la chance non
et de toutes façons de notre adn c'est
de pousser à l'émergence de la
champions' coup pour ça mais quand on
regarde on s'aperçoit que en irlande ou
qui a eu la chance d'avoir au rimac et
reuil en espagne où ils ont des joueurs
comme garcia des joueurs comme ram le
bélier sur la même période où on a
augmenté de 3% à eux ont baissé de 18%
oui donc voilà donc nos trois pour cent
ne sont pas satisfaisants et j'aurais
aimé qu'on fasse mieux et plus mais
quand on le remet en perspective par
rapport à ce qui s'est passé dans les
autres fédérations à l'international
federation golfique et bien on
s'aperçoit de nos 3 % sont pas si mal et
le confinement malheureusement on a
perdu en 2000 en 2020 on a perdu à peu
près 3% et là on est sur une année
historique puisqu'on est à à peu près 14
% par rapport à 2020 et on est surtout à
4% par rapport à 2010 9 qui pour nous
était notre année historique longtemps
la référence à la la et donc on peut
espérer donc il y ait cet effet raidir
foot que les jo qui sont peut-être plus
populaires j'admire la ryder cup ça
m'intéressait beaucoup les gens qui
connaissaient des alcools peut-être le
les jo c'est l'effet de la ryder cup
c'est certainement la seule compétition
de golf et peut-être avec tjo on verra
quel et peuvent avoir les gigots en tout
cas nous on se prépare à faire en sorte
que cet événement soit un événement
majeur pour le golf français mais pour
le sport français aussi l'objectif c'est
que un très grand nombre de personnes
découvrent le golfe et se disent tiens
mais pourquoi pas moi mais c'est vrai
que la ryder cup et et la compétition
qui passionne le plus les golfeurs voilà
ça c'est la compétition au monde qui est
certainement la plus populaire peut-être
que il ya une ouverture peut être rester
magique avec les jeux parce que pendant
toute la période d'organisation des jeux
vous baigner dans le sport est forcément
et vous vous zapper d'un sport un autre
et c'est l'occasion de découvrir des
sports que peut-être vous n'avez jamais
eu l'occasion de découvrir le golf est
avant tout un sport de passionnés et
c'est assez rare sauf pour de grands
événements comme la ryder cup où les
jeux que vous puissiez avoir des noms
golfeurs qui ce qui regarde un événement
golfique
j'en fais la fédération française de
danse c'est quoi 80 milles
non à peu près 4000 licenciés à vols
locaux vides après le après la crise
sanitaire - comme toutes les fédérations
mais c'est sa 80ème ils s'en serviront
alors vous allez être comme ça s'est
passé vous avez fait candidature pour
être pour être bienvenue aux jo il ya eu
un travail d'autres fédérations
internationales méchant qu'il faut
souligner surtout à la volonté du cio
d'avoir cette discipline et du coup joue
en particulier c'était une gros pari est
jeté a remercié le cojo parce que je
sais qu'ils ont énormément travaillé
c'était pas simple à c'était donc je
crois que la danse peut leur dire merci
pour le travail qui a été effectué et
les risques qui ont été pris pour les
endroits parce qu'il ya des gens et moi
le premier je suis pas forcément
familier de ça c'est quoi la différence
entre la danse sportive et la danse
qu'on peut aller voir d'aladdin sportive
il ya plusieurs disciplines où vous
allez le rock acrobatique que vous avez
les statines vous avez d un standard
vous avez plusieurs plusieurs
disciplines et en fait ce sont des
disciplines et qui sont qui sont
organisées au niveau international avec
un jeu avec avec des championnats du
monde avec des championnats de repas
c'est ce qui fait un petit peu la
différence entre les danses dites
artistique
les danses dites sportives en
l'entendant sportive c'est une grande
famille de danse et pour les jo ce sera
la brévine vente c'est ça le breaking
wave riding ans et alors là j'ai vu des
démonstrations un petit peu tout à
l'heure nous promenons c est qu on
pourrait définir le vrai qu'une danse
pour se tirer le break il s'est alors
fois une discipline spectaculaire
c'est une discipline ainsi les
disciplines sportives parce qu'il faut
une bonne condition physique mais il
faut surtout et son adn et c'est quand
même de la ricine disciplines
artistiques et on peut dire que ce qui
est intéressant dans cette discipline
c'est qu'elle revêt un petit peu tous
les éléments sportifs artistiques à est
ce les breakeurs tiennent beaucoup à
garder cette identité
dedans ça à la fois sportive et
artistique et ça se sait il ya des
équipes féminines équipes masculines ou
mixtes
non il ya beaucoup de compétition mixte
est parce qu elle et breaker à 2 ensuite
au niveau des championnats du monde qui
ont eu lieu et champion d'europe on a
des catégories féminines des catégories
masculines dans certaines compétitions
au niveau national au niveau local on
mixe souvent les garçons et les siens et
l'aele et les français alors on est beau
écoutez la france est une grande nation
du du breaking ça fait partie des trois
plus grandes nations au monde par la
culture saine des pays où il ya le plus
de manifestations de compétition et puis
c'est une la france et les breakeurs
compte beaucoup au niveau au niveau
international dans le mouvement à
breaking d'accord en 2020 cassé en 2024
à la province est à 2,24 après ce sera
ça sera bon quand ça sera ça sera un
sport un sport additionnel additionnel à
ce qu'on a bien quatre sports
additionnel donc à 24
enfin jacques philippe europe paraît
mieux comment vos skis et ses degrés
spécialistes elle met donc là le noeud
breaking fera partie des quatre sports
additionnels qui seront aux jeux
olympiques de paris nageurs philippe
gatien voulait de préciser c'est
peut-être préciser cette nouveauté qui
existe depuis tokyo en fait le cio offre
la possibilité au comité d'organisation
en plus du programme des sports qui est
imposé comme par exemple pour parer 2004
qu'on nous a imposée le programme de rio
les comités d'organisation ont la
possibilité d'ajouter des sports
additionnel pour enrichir ce programme
là et donc donne l'elysée
charles ferreira on a décidé de porter
nos choix sur des sports qui peut être
amener quelque chose d'un petit peu
différent par rapport à un programme qui
nous était imposé
et on s'est tourné vers des sports
résolument tournée vers la jeunesse qui
se pratique peut être assez facilement
qu'ils sortent un pipeau des stades et
qui amène le score dans les rues et donc
ce côté urbain est jeune a été
définitivement quelque chose qui a été
qui a été chercher par paris 2004
encore une fois dans le peu de marge de
manoeuvre qu'on avait un ses douze
épreuves c'est seulement 3 % du
programme
qu'est-ce qu'on pourrait amener comme
petite bouffée d'oxygène qui casse un
petit peu les codes et
et on s'est tourné vers les breaking
parce qu'on avait aussi pu ce succès de
cette de cette discipline aux jeux
olympiques de la jeunesse à buenos aires
est il y avait qui avait cartonné et
donc on s'est dit il ya peut-être un
coup à faire à part et 2024 et
l'ensemble des sports urbains auront un
écrin assez sympa puisqu'il se froncent
place de la concorde
donc on va on va leur offrir une des
images fantastiques et ce sport culture
patrimoine auquel on tenait pas mal
quand même
victoire formidable et c'est une
victoire historique à et c'est vrai je
rejoins ce qu'il disait jamais philippe
rey s'était quand même pas simple est
pour pour paris 2024 et quand même des
locaux jo d'avoir fait ce choix
unisyn artistique qui en a le mieux
sportivement il n'y a pas que il n'ya
pas que le breaking on a aussi le
patinage sur glace et qui est à la fois
un mix je veux dire artistique mx1 mix
positif mais après c'est vrai que ça aux
jeux olympiques de la jeunesse en
argentine où la france avait brillé
d'ailleurs puisqu'on une médaille
d'argent chez les garçons et une
cinquième place et chez les filles c'est
vrai que ça a eu un succès est
retentissant quoi il ya eu un public qui
a eu vraiment y ait vraiment un
engouement pour pour la discipline
incroyable on est serré donc c'est donc
là où il a dit que vous êtes beaucoup de
deux sportifs de haut niveau qui se
prépare pour 2021 sélection il ya voir
la discipline et sportivement avait
besoin d'être aidés donc on a dominé
statut haut niveau on a mis des équipes
en place
on a mis un directeur des équipes de
france qui s'occupa unicoop presque
uniquement du du breaking donc il a
fallu tout mettre en place pour essayer
d'obtenir à une ou deux médailles
jeux olympiques de paris 2024 et si j'ai
apprécié la raison c'est vrai que c'est
aussi une nouvelle image du sport qui
est à la fois
voilà peut-être plusieurs balles plus
belle la jeunesse est très très sensible
est d'ailleurs ça se voit dès qu'il ya
du breaking les jeunes aujourd'hui ça
touche tout tous les jeunes et c'est
vrai qu'ils sont aussi très présents sur
tout ce qui est réseau à réseaux sociaux
etc
ça peut donner à tous les cas un coup de
jeune pas par un certain côté à un jour
aux jeux de paris alors on va parler de
rugby avec didier entière parce que donc
cette équipe de filles de france s'est
qualifiée pour pour tokyo alors il faut
préciser aux jeux olympiques c'est du
rugby à 7 qui c'est quoi les vite qu'on
enlève un peu plus que les sommes devant
un peu c'est à dire qu'on a fait un
format de rugby qui se joue sur le même
terrain que celui sur lequel on joue à
15 contre 15 quand même alors il faut
courir donc il faut courir il faut
courir longtemps vite c'est très très
intense les matchs les matins beaucoup
plus court on fait deux fois sept
minutes
et donc voilà c'est un format qui
correspond un peu à l'ambiance aussi de
ces sports urbains c'est à dire que
c'est à son chêne c'est très festif
c'est très spectaculaire les filles nous
ont gagné 50 0 donc ça veut dire que ça
peut bien voilà on va on va d'un effet à
une hymne des faits à l'autre voilà il
ya des gestes techniques assez
spectaculaire donc
donc voilà c'est là aussi un tournoi qui
se déroule sur trois jours et donc
avec souvent beaucoup d'ambiance aussi
dans les tribunes ya une tradition un
petit peu de très très festive qui
viennent en fait des étudiants qu'il est
souvent voir les matches en fait les
spectateurs du rugby sait sont souvent
déguisés il ya un côté assez marrant et
par contre c'est un sport spectaculaire
mais m'est très difficile physiquement
on en avait on a des athlètes alors
c'est pas renoncé c'est les mêmes qui
jouent à 15 à 7
on en a certains qui les a on a c'est
vraiment une preuve une préparation
parfaite et martigues et on a retrouvé
j'avais discuté avec des entraîneurs de
vol et balkarie jouannet soi ou donc on
a un peu les mêmes
c'est un peu les mêmes différences que
ce qu'on a on prend le volley en salle
et le beach volley on a travaillé avec
le basket qui avec la nouvelle pratique
et le 3-3 et donc on retrouve ses
dimensions la salle iront à des gabarits
un peu moins costaud un peu moins grand
qui sont plus en plus vive plus rapide
donc voilà c'est un peu un peu différent
c'est un peu différent donc des deux mi
temps de 7 minutes et très voilà donc
ouais moi c'est jouer à dos voilà à fond
du début à la fin on est alors non pas
les avec pascal grizot justement de du
golfe qui avait déjà été aux jo avant
avant 2013 le rugby aussi enfin là on a
l'impression que c'est un sport nouveau
me l'a déjà été
dans ses répliques dans des dents des
années alors très lointaine presse jeudi
au début du 20e siècle parce que pierre
de coubertin était aussi arbitres de
rugby
elles ont donc oui il ya le rugby à
paris en 1900 et je crois que 1900 1908
1920 1924 et donc on défend on est sorti
des jeux en 1924 après la victoire des
américains qui avaient fait jouer des
footballeurs américains qui étaient
professionnels déjà à l'époque ça met un
peu offusqué c'est drôle on savait
offusqué un peu nos amis britanniques
qui donc est dans la philosophie du
score de l'époque qu'elle n'atterrisse
malades assez négligent pas qu'on ait
des gens professionnels qui viennent
pratiquer ce sport c'est qu'on a on a
quitté sanaa quitter les jeux en 2024
pour y revenir comme le golf en 2016 à
rio
et donc est donc voilà c'est la deuxième
fois qu'on reviendra au jeu et puis
évidemment à paris viendra de venir à
paris juste un petit mot à dire mais je
crois que pour les jeux tokyo ce qui est
important aussi c'est vraiment prendre
en compte les athlètes ils se préparent
depuis maintenant cinq ans il y en a
certains qui vont arrêter leur carrière
suite aux jeux de tokyo donc je crois
qu'il faut vraiment les soutenir parce
que j'aime l'air de déconsidérer la
manquez pas ce que je voulais dire avec
il ya une aspiration ici en france nous
4 mai bon bah tout le monde attend ça
évidemment il faut être très respectueux
l'ajustement des athlètes
vraiment le passage de relais et est ce
symbolique c'est à dire vraiment que à
la fin des jeux tokyo c'est parti pour
paris donc fait formidablement quant au
bureau a pu quand je sais pas s'il ya
des paris sportifs et j'ai vu qu'il ya
déjà pour la nouvelle zélande les états
unis le canada l'australie le brésil la
grande-bretagne de kenya fidji la chine
et la russie
et on a des chances avec les filles on a
je compte vraiment des sentiers
chrétiens se sont bien qualifiées elles
ont beaucoup travaillé on est on est
dans la même situation un petit peu que
que tous les athlètes c'est à dire on a
plus de références et c'est vrai qu'on a
quasiment un an et demi sans compétition
le thé piot le tournoi de qualification
était vraiment la première compétition
officielle qui se déroulait donc c'est
vrai qu'on est un petit peu en manque de
marquer 2 et de repères dans crise afin
qu'elles soient en forme
elles font enfants elles font déterminer
voilà l on a vraiment emmené un moral de
vainqueur
donc on va voir et je pense qu'on en
effet elles ont de réelles chances de
médaille et c'est bien que ça soit des
filles aussi qui représente la france en
rugby c'est vrai que là aussi comme
comme dans l'annoncé
c'est ce que didier c'est la liaison un
peu de durban et des fleurs et le fait
que ça soit d'aussi des femmes qu'ils
soient là ça il ya une modernité paquet
je crois que c'est aussi très précurseur
en terme de l'équipe de mixité mais
c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui la mixité en
général dans le sport c'est un vrai vent
nouveau et qui est qui qui participe
justement à une vraie évolution des
mentalités je crois quand on voit les
athlètes
de tous les sports féminins inspire
vraiment le respect et c'est ça qui est
fabuleux dans le sport c'est la
performance en fait à la halle a pas de
couleur à l'as pas de religion à la pas
celle de genre et voilà c'est le respect
simplement devoir dire ce que sont
capables de faire les jours des athlètes
jean-félix est juste un mot sur sur ce
que vient de dire didier sur la parité
notamment et souligné qu' à paris de
1024 ça sera la première fois dans
l'histoire des jeux qui aura 50 %
l'assiette masculins 1 50% à 13 films et
la parité la parité sera total le cio à
travailler en ce sens avec l'ensemble
des fédérations internationales
donc on est assez fier de pouvoir porter
ce message qui est un vrai message aussi
sociétales et qui fait partie de notre
ambition en termes d'héritage
c'est la première fois dans l'histoire
et la première fois en histoire et c'est
un clin d'oeil à 1900 des jo de paris où
c'est la première fois que les femmes
intégrer les jeux elle était 2% à
l'époque et donc on voit le chemin qui a
été parcouru
et elle se rend 50% des représentants
des athlètes en 2024
c'est aujourd'hui que vous avez bien
fait de 2,7 précision christophe bonnal
autant les alors du cyclisme je disais
un peu différent c'est à dire que c'est
en effet le sport qui était le plus
représenté aux jo depuis le début un
depuis le début fait partie des cinq
sports je crois qu'on est là la france à
42 médailles d'or comme en cyclisme à a
dû compter que je vous crois
certainement parce qu'on a on a eu
l'habitude pendant de longues heures à
caudéran viande on a dominé
la discipline de la piste notamment qui
peut rapporter jusqu'à douze titres je
suis content et borloo et bien d'autres
depuis
mais c'est essentiellement sur la piste
et puis bon là avec jeannie longo mais
c'est essentiellement sur la piste et
c'est sur la route que qu'on a fait nos
médailles dit dernièrement dans les
dernières années on a fait des médailles
en bmx donc avec caroline chausson et
laëtitia le corguillé en 2008
et puis également en vtt quand vtt
devenue olympique avec absalon plusieurs
fois et jean christophe péraud de
teghime 5e soit 5 épaules la route la
piste parce qu'on connaît à peu près il
parle très fort derrière
c'est le break dance wii seront alors au
buzzer alors la route la piste de bmx
but sinon j'ai une bx freestyle voilà
donc et le mountain bike mountain bike
c'est le seul vtt oui oui celle vtt xc
au donc une discipline qui est olympique
depuis depuis 1996 où on a fait
régulièrement des les médailles soit des
médailles d'or je vous lis avec absalon
judy pressé mais donc donc le vtt mais
pour faire écho aux peut-être à
l'ambiance et puis aux nouvelles
disciplines nous a et surtout aux
disciplines urbaines pour la première
fois en cyclisme nous avons une nouvelle
discipline c'est le bmx freestyle et
c'est vraiment une nouveauté parce que
donc ce sera pas de la danse mais ça va
être une prestation aérienne notée
avec avec des tricks est une discipline
très spectaculaire qui obéit à des codes
vestimentaires des codes musicaux et je
pense que voilà c'est ça ça se règle
dans cette mouvance que veulent les
échos jo actuelle jeux de sports urbains
de discipline fun je n'ai et voilà donc
c'est une nouveauté pour nous c'est vrai
que vrai tendance à 20 dans l'évolution
du sport
ouais c'est pour cette raison on sentait
un non sens on sent effectivement se
vendent et des sports urbains arriver
c'est pour ça qu'on s'est tourné vers
ses sports qui sont quelque part
connecter avec avec leur époque avec la
jeunesse qui peut-être se pratique se
consomme on évoquait tout à l'heure les
réseaux sociaux et ce sont des scores
sur lesquels il ya des communautés assez
forte
effectivement en termes de communication
de retentissement et de relais d'image
ou de houe de vocations c'est quelque
chose qui est important et on en a pris
on a tenu compte effectivement oui et je
regarde pas ce qu'il écrivait de
distinguo y est stocké pendant il dit
d'une des ambitions de paris 2024 c'est
de contribuer à mettre plus de sport
dans la vie des gens pour mieux utiliser
toutes les solutions qu'il peut offrir
en matière de santé d'éducation
d'inclusion ou encore de changement de
regard sur le handicap
on peut pas mieux dire après c'est vrai
que c'est ça aussi le sport oui c'est ça
évidemment les athlètes qu'on admire et
voilà qu'on vient à applaudir et et
quand on voit là mais on ne peut pas
forcément être l'heureux auteur mais
mais c'est aussi ça c'est aussi le
partage c'est aussi le regard sur
l'autre complètement en a on a tendance
en fait à réduire et c'est sa mission
principale comité d'organisation la
livraison des compétitions sportives
donc on doit bien évident s'assurer à ce
qu'elles vont se dérouler dans des
conditions parfaites mais je crois que
la volonté de ce comité d'organisation
et de son président anthony s'est
véritablement d'aller encore plus loin
et de permettre durant les trois
prochaines années
que la plateforme par et 2004 puis c'est
une caisse de résonance justement pour
les multiples vocations du sport cette
machine à solution que ça peut
représenter dans la société on parle du
sport santé bien évidemment ce qui est
des enjeux majeurs aujourd'hui quand on
voit la sédentarité qui gagne notamment
les plus jeunes qui sont souvent en
souffrance et en obésité quand on parle
d'inclusion quand on parle de 2,2 de
mixité et de parité enfin voilà tous ces
sujets sociétaux je pense que le sport a
véritablement un lien très fort pour les
faire avancer et je pense que paris 2004
a aussi vocation à porter ces sujets et
à les mettre sur la table au travers de
leurs programmes d'héritage et
d'engagement assez ambitieux justement
les uns et les autres sur ferrer âge
parce qu'il ya des gens qui grâce à
grâce à l'ado sportives se sont révélés
peut-être sur sortie de deux chemins qui
était plus sinueux sur lesquels va
fermer aujourd'hui le rôle des
fédérations a drôlement échanges jcct qu
elle ait pas on n'a pas un rôle et une
mission uniquement sportive
aujourd'hui les enjeux et les missions
qu'on a au niveau des fédérations elle
est autant sportif que social
aujourd'hui à travers à travers le sport
le suivi socioprofessionnel et très
importants comme comme l'a dit jeanne
philippe a tous les problèmes de société
aujourd'hui un autre ministère et nos
politiques se tourne beaucoup vers les
fédérations pour venir en soutien social
à la jeunesse et au sport santé
et est il faut dire qu'aujourd'hui ça
fait partie des grandes missions d'aidé
fédération pascal grizot contrairement à
peut-être parce que le grand public
pourrait croire le golf aussi une
dimension sociale il ya des jeunes
ils viennent de quartiers difficiles il
ya évidemment le long d'un handicap
ok très bien représentées il ya des
formidables joueurs c'est vrai qu'il ya
une dédiée cette dimension sociale aussi
lorsqu'on ce qu'on sait pas suffisamment
et encore une fois l'objectif c'est pas
du tout d'aller faire une compétition
entre les sports en nombre de licenciés
mais le golf est le premier sport
individuel au monde en nombre de
pratiquants ça c'est quelque chose qu'il
faut qu'il faut savoir
ça c'est beaucoup plus dans les pays
anglo saxons ou en asie dsr des sports
les plus regardés à la télévision c'est
un des sports qui est le plus regardé
mais rien à voir là quand même avec des
sports collectifs comme le rugby ou le
football mais en terme de nombre de
licenciés de nombre de pratiquants le le
golf est le premier sport individuel
quand on a eu la chance d'accueillir la
ryder cup on s'était engagé pour gagner
la candidature à construire sans
équipement compact urbain qui sont des
équipements qui sont comme leurs noms
l'indiquent plus compact et qui dit plus
compactes dites aussi beaucoup moins
cher en coûts d'exploitation et et on y
passe beaucoup moins de temps puis qu'on
peut mettre près des ados mais dans les
villages après enfants un accès un accès
beaucoup plus facile et certainement les
chiffres dont je vous parlais tout à
l'heure par rapport à d'autres
fédérations qui n'ont pas eu ce
programme d'ouvertures de parcours
compact urbain est certainement un des
outils qui nous a permis de mieux
résister par rapport à d'autres
fédérations qui l ont baissé en termes
de licenciés et aujourd'hui il ya cette
image que peut encore avoir le golf un
sport élitiste et est totalement infondé
puisque enfin toutes et toutes les
populations sont représentés aujourd'hui
dans les golfs que ce soit dans les
parcours compact urbain que ce soit dans
des golfs qui sont des golfs des golfs
commerciaux où vous rentrez vous payez
un green fille et vous pouvez accéder et
il ya encore le modèle évidemment des
golfs associatif mais qui a plutôt
tendance à diminuer au profit des golfs
commerciaux et des parcours compact
urbain
et bogho d'initiative sont fait les
guerres des jeunes notamment
alors ça c'est un de nos enjeux
principal enjeu et je vois moi je
regarde beaucoup ce qui se passe dans
l'est dans les sports collectifs et
quand je regarde de quelle façon les
sports collectifs s'occupe des jeunes
enfants je suis très admiratif nous on a
un chiffre qui est terrible on à 78 %
des enfants qui arrête le golfe après
deux heures salle et ça c'est vraiment
un chiffre dramatique parce que
l'objectif c'est pas d'aller en chercher
c'est déjà d'arriver à concert les
maintenir et de réfléchir à la façon
dont il faut enseigner le golf
aujourd'hui est là aujourd'hui c'est
très symptomatique quand on voit des
enfants on veut leur les faire jouer une
première fois au golf on leur fait taper
un coup sûr un practice de golf
mais quand dans un sport collectif on a
envie de faire découvrir le sport
collectif on donne une balle et tout de
suite il ya un match d'une équipe contre
une autre équipe et ça c'est ce que
veulent les enfants et c'est ce qu'ont
fait mal au golf donc il faut absolument
initiation aussi il ya une initiation
mais vous savez le moi je compare ces
initiation au solfège c'est à dire que
quand vous commencez la musique vous
faites du solfège mais ce qui amuse les
enfants mais c'est de jouer le lundi au
moule et le même si vous jouez mal
vous n'allez pas devenir mozart tout de
suite mais ce qui les importe c'est que
celui de mal joué on s'en fiche
tout le monde dans sport collectif n'est
pas zidane mais l'important c'est de
faire jouer et de les faire jouer de la
façon la plus appropriée et la façon la
plus appropriée c'est de les faire jouer
les uns contre les autres et le golf a
ce côté magique d'être un sport
individuel qui peut se pratiquer dans le
cadre d'un sport collectif en équipe
seulement et c'est ça qui amuse les
enfants qui l'utilisent beaucoup plus et
jusqu'à présent on l'a certainement très
mal faits puisqu'on perd 78 % des
enfants et c'est pas de la faute des
enfants c'est de notre faute
il faut qu'on se remette en question
très belles promesses à tenir christophe
en a eu évidemment il ya des champions à
vélo mais le vélo est en train
d'exploser en france ça aussi c'est ça
vous ça vous intéresse je suppose et oui
donc ma comme ça a déjà été dit le sport
et les fédérations doivent répondre à un
certain nombre de politiques publiques
le vélo de la dette un outil pour faire
une course et pour arriver le premier
sur une ligne ou pour faire des sauts
sur un skate park c'est aussi un outil
de déplacement et dans le cadre de la
mobilité on s'aperçoit avec les enjeux
climatiques auront encourage les gens la
population à se déplacer d'une manière
propre et de plus en plus en vélo donc
au sein de la fédération mais bon c'est
certain c'est un programme
interministériel mais au sein de la
fédération particulièrement nous
développons le savoir rouler à vélo dont
il y avait un atelier là qui a été
présenté c'est aujourd'hui sur les sur
la journée olympique donc là c'est pour
former les enfants notamment les verts
déjà d'un cfc voilà ces trois blocs un
premier bloc qui est apprendre à faire
du vélo le deuxième blog c'est voilà la
sécurité routière et puis le troisième
blog c est être autonome sur 20 sur la
route ou les pistes cyclables donc la
fédération française de cyclisme est
vraiment investi dans ce programme
interministériel
donc ça c'est pour pour les enfants on
s'occupe aussi des publics adultes avec
un programme s'appelle la remise en
selle donc aussi le vélo électrique à
faire du vélo mais certains noms il faut
savoir savoir les adultes qui n'ont pas
refait d'une impression c'est faire
concède tout de faire du vélo à la
remise en selle
puis après pour compléter la panoplie
d'aidés publiques on est aussi très
actif sur les publics seniors
notamment avec un programme dans les
yvelines la de cyclisme mobile où on va
dans les ehpad on a des équipes qui vont
dans les ehpad avec des vélos des vélos
d'appartement et puis on fait pratiquer
les personnes âgées est donc là c'est
dans un objectif de santé de
conservation de la santé la voilà on est
on essaye de derry leur éveloppement
d'autres choses que la partie
compétition qu'on sait faire dans nos
clubs et didier retière
quand on regarde le rugby au fond on a
toujours la passion qu'à une certaine
canalisation de la violence parce qu'il
pourrait ce qui pourrait exploser et une
grande morale chez des joueurs c'est à
dire qu'il ya très peu de contestations
par rapport au football mais des
arbitres des décisions arbitrales
c'est vrai que c'est aussi une leçon de
vie quoi il faut savoir que le rugby a
été inventé pour ça on est pas c'est à
dire que fabien des collèges anglo
saxons ou en fait on les enseignants ont
utilisé des pratiques assez l'histoire
souvent du sport avec les les internes
faisait jouer au football à la façon de
l'école de rugby c'est à dire avec un
peu d'engagement physique et longs
qu'ils ont ils ont utilisé utiliser le
rugby justement pour éduquer les jeunes
et donc ce qui fait que par exemple le
rôle du capitaine c'est le représentant
des élèves
l'entraîneur était souvent un enseignant
qui n'était pas un enseignant de sports
qui faisait qui enseignait d'autres
matières mais qui en même temps fait
était donc l'entraîneur de rugby donc
cet héritage en fait en quelque sorte
est resté et ce qui fait que en effet ce
qu'il faut comprendre dans l'activité
rugby c'est qu'il n'y a pas de limites
de charges c'est-à-dire qu'on peut
rentrer dans un adversaire
à partir du moment où on a le ballon ou
si on est adversaire de vouloir plaquer
le joueur de porteur de balle il n'y a
pas de cas pas de limites de charge
la seule limite c'est là c'est la perte
du contrôle
en fait on a on a des règles assez
précises c'est ceinture et un joueur et
l'amener au sol en le tenant entre
dessous des épaules et les jambes et un
moment donné mais si on l'engagement
devient trop grand on peut pas réussir
le geste technique et surtout au risque
de se mettre en danger et donc de
prendre une pénalité
donc c'est cette dualité qui a
engagement contrôle qui fait qu'à un
moment donné on travaille sur des
notions de courage de solidarité de
respect aussi des règles et je crois que
ça c'est voilà c'est un essai
passionnant il ya l'activité et c'est ça
qui était bien et juste un petit mot
pour dire aussi ce qui me semble
passionnant dans tous les sports c'est
qu'en fait on est ce qui est incroyable
c'est l'ensemble des talents de la
diversité des talents que les gens
expriment un golfeur il ya ce côté cette
précision
cette régularité se rassure à la
concentration la résistance à la
pression et tout il ya la créativité
dans certaines autres activités et c'est
ça qui est bien c'est vrai qu'en fait on
se rend compte moi je les ai vécus avec
en découvrant le rugby fauteuil
oui non c'est c'est incroyable on voit
des gens qui sont en situation de
handicap parfois très lourds et des
tétraplégiques mais ce sont deux
virtuoses du fauteuil et moines ont mis
sur le fauteuil et pour le coup c'était
moi le handicap les titres services moi
non je l'étais vraiment laissé sa vie se
passe bien il ya en fait en réalité je
pense qu'il ya le sport qui convient à
chacun chacune des personnes et on doit
pouvoir révéler le talent qu'on a on au
fond nous dans une activité qui nous
correspond je crois que c'est ça le
message c'est à dire que cette diversité
en fait de pratiquer elle doit me servir
à moment donné a révélé ce qu'on est
juste les faits je trouve ça vous fait
vous avez raison de parler d'aidé aux
handicapés du québec parce que on a de
l'admiration pour les pour les grands
champions je crois qu'on a encore
peut-être plus parfois d'admiration pour
les handicapés parce qu'il faut moi je
vous fais une fois une réflexion parce
qu'il jouait donc il faut pas venir il
faut pas en avoir plusieurs
ils seront devant avec les fauteuils qui
tombe par terre et elle renvoie sur le
coup
les gars faites attention et tout ça et
y en a un qui m'a regardé il fait on est
handicapé on n'est pas malade est en
fait un plaisir incroyable c'est qu'il
nous faut aussi changer le regard sur
eux quand on vraiment les côtoie ses on
n'est plus dans la compassion c'est à
dire que on est vraiment dans le respect
des lieux ce sont des sportifs de haut
niveau et ça et ça c'est plus grand mais
flash qui peuvent envoyer enfin quand on
voit les jeux paralympiques
c'est incroyable ce qu'ils sont capables
de faire et voilà jean-philippe non je
voulais juste rajouter là-dessus sur ce
que vient de dire didier sur
effectivement l'image ou la perception
qu'on peut avoir et la différence qui
est traditionnellement un raccourci un
peu facile entre le monde olympique le
monde paralympique les athlètes
olympiques la tête par un temps pour la
première fois aussi une nouvelle fois de
l'histoire
on a une équipe de france unis il ya
plus de france olympique est une équipe
de france c'est l'équipe de france qui
est composée d'athlètes valides ou
d'athlètes andy et et il représente la
même équipe de france et je pense que
c'est un symbole aussi assez fort et
c'est ça une marque aussi quelque part
sociétal d'intégration et paris 1 4 de
faire du sport et des jeux un modèle
d'inclusion absolument l'inclusion voilà
un dernier mot que ta nea je laisserais
après la conclusion sur les souhaits
pour 2024 mais est ce que finalement
vous avez représenté des sports
différents les uns les autres
mais ce qu finalement vous avez
l'impression de faire partie de la même
équipe du sport ça je pense que c'est là
la magie du comité d'organisation
d'abord la chance de savoir qu'on va
organiser les jeux dans notre pays ça
fédère les fédérations je pense que
c'est la première fois où les présidents
de fédérations sont réunis de faire
aussi souvent et bien sûr ça crée des
liens
on apprend à se connaître il ya eu des
élections dans les fédérations où les
présidents ont changé beaucoup de
présidents ont changé et le fait d'avoir
cet événement en ligne de mire je pense
que ça aide à se réunir
la force des projets c'est toujours ce
qu'il ya de plus important est allé
belles paroles mais d'avoir un projet et
projets communs projets communs comme
comme paris 2024 je pense que c'est ça
qui nous permet aujourd'hui de tous rêvé
et de rêver plus forts autour d'un très
grand événement
j'ai fait rare vous êtes vous et voilà
vous accédez à cette équipe là ça fait
rêver
mais toulouse pour france et les
présidents des deux fédérations c'est un
rêve on est tous
on est tous réunis autour de ce projet
et c'est vrai que c'est une c'est une
façon d un projet encore de réunir
encore plus le sport français et on est
tous derrière derrière paris et 2024
pour que ce projet sont à la fois un
projet une réussite sportive sociale
mais aussi une réussite du pays il faut
que tout le coup que tout le peuple
participe à cet événement exceptionnel
ou t2 des journées comme cela jean
philippe gatien le souhait pour 2011 14
parce que dans votre esprit y as
l'idée peut-être se dire on espère que
la crise sanitaire ça sera derrière nous
non mais c'est bien évidemment d'arriver
à notre à notre ambition c'est jeu on
les a voulus depuis le début de cette
phase de candidature et l'organisation
spectaculaire exemplaires sur le sueur
sur plein de ses dimensions économiques
soient dimension environnementale sur
dimension sociétale
on les a voulu aussi ouvert pour la
première fois on va faire participer le
grand public à une épreuve de marathon
pour tous ou une épreuve cycliste
également de masses event donc déjà que
l'ensemble de ses ambitions soient soit
exaucé que le sport français brille qui
est beaucoup de médailles
un des facteurs de succès aussi des jeux
c'est si le pays hôte
amen amen plein de médailles donc voila
et et surtout et ça rejoint un petit peu
ce que disait pascal 7 cette équipe unie
que l'on forme
il ya un comité d'organisation mais en
2024 il va disparaître
qu'est ce qu'on va laisser après
quelques louis saïa discussions suite
année en termes d'héritage
est ce que le mouvement sportif sera
plus fort il sera renforcé est ce qu'il
y aura plus de pratiquants exclure en
capacité de les accueillir dans les
clubs et c'est donc tous ces sujets là
qu'on porte à bras le corps aujourd'hui
et qui sont une ambition forte
on espère forcément que qui vont se
réaliser c'est notre souhait le plus
cher est que ce soit surtout une
ambiance de fête incroyable et que sais
je marque l'histoire et on est tous dans
la même
dans la même famille pour livrer cet
événement et qui marquent l'histoire des
jeux là vous avez raison de dire voilà
il y aura un après de 8,24 je renvoie
quand même votre site parce qu'il ya
aussi un avion et va y avoir un été très
ludique et très sportif as we
d'ambitionner on va essayer
effectivement d'encourager cette
pratique du sport justement pour qu'ils
aient un lien avec cette équipe de
france est donc d'encourager avec le 06
88 24
whatsapp envoyer vos messages vos vidéos
etc on va aussi faire vivre sur des
sites de célébration notamment des
collectivités autres qui vont organiser
les moyens de vivre les jeux sur les
places publiques grâce au concours de
france télévisions également pour
commencer à la culture est un petit peu
ce pays à ce que sont les jeux et vibrer
derrière l'équipe de france
on aura aussi sur le sur l'ensemble du
territoire et au travers des sites aires
de jeux des vocations aussi à promouvoir
le sport bref on va on va avoir un été
sportif et on prépare le 8 août cette
bascule tokyo avec un événement
fantastique au trocadéro
face à la tour eiffel qui va qui va
marquer j'espère aussi les esprits qui
va marquer l'entrée de paris du 24 dans
24h 24 et après les les yeux du monde
seront tournés vers nous et on aura on
aura besoin de ça fait du bien à tout le
monde
oui exactement merci infiniment tous les
5 merci beaucoup merci beaucoup merci à
patrice et à ses invités et si vous
souhaitez suivre toutes les étapes d'ici
à l'organisation des jeux sachez qu'une
cérémonie de passation sera organisée
avec tokyo le 8 août prochain à 14
heures au pied de la tour eiffel des
répétitions déjà eu lieu on nous promet
un spectacle créatif ambitieux avec la
participation est de la patrouille de
france c'est la fin de ce premier
magazine paris et 2024 on se retrouve au
mois de septembre pour faire vivre cette
devise olympique plus vite plus haut
plus fort ensemble très bel été sur tv
[Musique]